aquí tengo tres escenarios distintos con
una célula inmersa en una solución la
membrana celular es este círculo magenta
y las moléculas de agua están
representadas por estos círculos que
tenemos aquí de color azul también están
estos solutos dentro de una solución
acuosa los cuales están representados
con estos círculos de color amarillo
claramente exageren en la diferencia de
tamaño entre las moléculas del agua y
las partículas de absoluto relativo al
tamaño de la célula pero lo hice para
que podamos visualizar lo que está
sucediendo vamos a suponer que esta
membrana celular es decir esta bicapa
lipídica es el impermeable lo que
significa que permitirá el paso de las
moléculas del agua hacia adentro y hacia
afuera entonces una molécula del agua
puede ir de adentro hacia afuera o una
molécula del agua puede ir de afuera
hacia adentro pero vamos a suponer que
el paso de las partículas de soluto no
es posible y es por eso que tenemos una
membrana semipermeable es
me hable a ciertas cosas o también lo
podemos decir como que tenemos una
permeabilidad selectiva ahora qué es lo
que pensamos que podría pasar bueno
primero puedes observar que tenemos una
menor concentración de soluto
afuera que la que tenemos adentro
entonces en cualquier momento dado
tendremos que las moléculas del agua
irán de afuera hacia adentro de afuera
hacia adentro de afuera hacia adentro y
también algunas moléculas del agua irán
de adentro hacia afuera muy bien pero
que es lo más probable que pase qué es
lo que va a pasar más en un cierto
periodo de tiempo bueno las moléculas de
agua que están afuera serán menos
obstruidas por las partículas de soluto
y de esto hablamos en el vídeo de
osmosis si sucede que esta molécula se
mueve en esta dirección
bueno lo más probable es que va a lograr
atravesar la membrana y si nos fijamos
en esta molécula del agua y suponemos
que se mueve en esta dirección
va a ser obstruida por esta partícula
a lo mejor está moviendo hacia atrás y
choca contra esta partícula de soluto y
después rebotan entonces las moléculas
de agua que están adentro tienen más
obstáculos tienen menor probabilidad de
interactuar con la membrana o dicho de
otra manera tienen menor probabilidad de
moverse en la dirección adecuada para
salir porque están siendo obstruidas por
estas partículas de solutos a pesar de
eso tendremos moléculas de agua
moviéndose hacia adentro ya sea fuera en
algún periodo dado pero habrá una mayor
probabilidad de que entren moléculas del
agua a que salgan eso quiere decir que
tendremos un flujo un flujo de entrada
de entrada neto de h2o de h2o y en una
situación como ésta donde hay una célula
en una solución que tiene menor
concentración de soluto y es importante
recordar que nos referimos absoluto que
no pueda atravesar la membrana la
membrana no es permeable a este soluto
llamamos a esta situación a este tipo de
solución donde las células
hiram le llamamos un tipo de solución y
fotónica así que ésta de aquí va a ser
una solución solución
ivo tónica y bo tónica
tú
y acá una solución hipotónico en
cualquier momento que hablemos de
hipotónico o como veremos más adelante
de isotónica o hipertónico estaremos
hablando de concentraciones relativas a
un soluto que no puede atravesar algún
tipo de membrana y bueno recuerda que
por el prefijo hipo que seguramente has
visto en otras palabras este prefijo
significa menos de algo en este caso
tenemos una menor concentración de
soluto en la solución que dentro de la
célula y debido a esto tendremos osmosis
tendremos moléculas del agua que irán de
afuera hacia adentro y esto genera
presión en la célula lo que va a hacer
que las células se expandan esta célula
se va a expandir y de hecho si tiene la
suficiente presión la célula podría
inclusive explotar pero bueno ahora
vayamos al siguiente escenario en este
escenario tenemos aproximadamente la
misma concentración de solutos afuera
que adentro de la célula en esta
situación la prueba
de que una molécula de agua en un
periodo dado vaya de afuera hacia
adentro o de adentro hacia afuera es la
misma esto quiere decir que no va a
haber un flujo de entrada o de salida
neto del agua ojo siempre vamos a tener
moléculas entrando y saliendo de esta
célula pero no habrá ningún flujo de
salida o de entrada
neto es más déjeme escribirlo ningún
flujo neto ningún flujo flujo neto y
aquí me falta un acento bien en este
caso en donde tenemos un tipo de
solución donde hay la misma
concentración de soluto en la solución
que adentro de la célula la llamamos una
solución isotónica así que esta de aquí
es una solución solo
acción isotónica y su tónica y el
prefijo eso significa que tenemos cosas
iguales es decir tenemos la misma
concentración de soluto y por lo tanto
no tenemos flujo neto en las soluciones
y potonik as tenemos que el agua entra a
la célula las células se expanden esto
es muy parecido a un globo que se infla
y en las soluciones isotónicas no hay
flujo neto y por supuesto te puedes
imaginar que en este último escenario
tenemos una mayor concentración de
soluto afuera de la célula que adentro
de ella primero pensemos cómo voy a
llamar a esto bueno pues esta de aquí va
a ser una solución solución y vamos a
usar el prefijo hiper porque en este
caso tengo una mayor concentración
afuera que adentro de la célula tengo
más concentración afuera así
será una solución hipertónica y ver
tónica tónica con nuestro prefijo hiper
y otra vez más este soluto no puede
atravesar la membrana pero las moléculas
de agua sí por lo que vamos a tener
algunas moléculas de agua que entren
algunas moléculas de agua que salgan
pero las moléculas de adentro tendrán
menos dificultades para salir que las de
afuera para entrar entonces tendremos un
flujo de salida neto del agua esto es
porque hay una mayor probabilidad de que
las cosas de adentro vayan hacia afuera
esta de aquí salga esta otra también
salga que está por ejemplo entre porque
va a ser obstruida o va a chocar con
alguna partícula de soluto van a ser
retenidas de distintas maneras y en esta
situación donde el agua escapa de la
célula la célula puede arrogarse y
terminar algo más o menos así como una
célula un poco arrugada esto es porque
la célula va a perder la presión que
ejerce el agua en la membrana celular y
de hecho se puede ver esto
temas biológicos si tú pones un glóbulo
rojo en una solución y fotónica bueno el
glóbulo rojo se vería muy inflado más o
menos así el agua entrará en él y éste
se va a expandir se va a expandir y se
verá como un glóbulo rojo demasiado
inflado e inclusive podría explotar este
es el caso en el que tenemos un glóbulo
rojo en una solución hipotética ahora
qué pasará en una solución isotónica
bueno pues se verá como estamos
acostumbrados a ver a los glóbulos rojos
vamos a ver un glóbulo rojo más o menos
así inclusive va a tener una pequeña
depresión justo en el centro como
estamos acostumbrados algo más o menos
así en este caso la depresión se expande
se va a expandir y entonces este es un
glóbulo rojo como estamos acostumbrados
a verlo y qué va a pasar en una solución
hipertónica en una solución hipertónica
veremos a la célula un poco arrugada
porque el agua escapará del blog
lo rojo algo más o menos así porque
tendremos un flujo de salida en las
moléculas del agua